also es ist ein durcheinander wieder
einmal in deutschland und wir wollen uns
mal einen überblick verschaffen wie das
die wirtschaft wie us-einzelhändler
betrifft in deutschland und schalten
dazu so ein bisschen quer durch
deutschland und fangen an mit einem
schreibwarenhändler in leipzig und zwar
mit manuell rot und dort herr rothe ist
die bizarre situation bei ihnen im
geschäft das für die schreibwaren die
sie verkaufen die 3g regel geld aber für
die postdienstleistungen die sie angeben
anbieten die genau umgekehrt für die
schreibwaren gilt zweig und für die
postgeschäfte die sie auch anbieten gilt
3g wie setzen sie das um alles in der
welt um in ihrem geschäft
das ist nur dass das verrückte gerade
jetzt auch in dieser zeit dass man
teilweise gar nicht so richtig logisch
nachvollziehen kann was gilt den mann
und macht das sinn also bei uns ist es
wirklich so dass wir in dieser situation
halt die die streitbare eigentlich mit
mit ganz konsequent konsequente zweig
regel nur verkaufen dürfen und alles was
irgendwie post oder post nah ist die
können wir einfach so durchwinken sind
dieselben kunden im selben laden fragt
man sich macht das sinn bringt und das
weiter hilft das uns wirklich in der
situation herr roth sie sind im
vergangenen jahr auf vielen
weihnachtsartikeln hängen geblieben denn
wir waren auch dann im lockdown was
fordern sie von der politik wenn es
jetzt wieder härtere maßnahmen gibt
ja die die grundsätzliche frage ist
hilft jetzt wirklich wieder in
konsequenter lockdown und sind diese die
begleiterscheinungen die nebenwirkungen
von so einem konsequenten lockdown auch
wirklich zielführend also wenn ich bin
ich mich einfach erstmal auch aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht frage wo kommt
das geld her also das zeigt ja auch dass
steuerzahler
und irgendwie zahlt man dass er doppelt
bezahlen das ja zum einen
aus denen aus die überbrückungshilfen
die ausgezahlt werden müssen wir zahlen
das zu zweit natürlich auch aus den
fehlenden steuereinnahmen und da frage
ich mich bringt uns das jetzt auch auf
dauer weiter oder hätten wir jetzt leute
auf biegen und brechen was natürlich
ziel sein muss aber auch in der
perspektive wo ist das problem wenn das
geld fehlt jetzt ins gesundheitssystem
und so weiter besonders in sachsen ist
die lage ja schlimm bei ihnen weiß ich
eben auch viele menschen nicht impfen
lassen wie sieht es bei ihnen aus sind
sie geimpft
ich bin geimpft
jetzt mittlerweile auch gepustet bei aus
dem ladengeschäft in alle geimpft
in der familie sind ja alle geimpft die
kinder natürlich noch nicht haben wir
haben drei kinder zwei töchter neun
jahre sechs jahren rund anderthalb jahre
aber auch dort hat zum beispiel diesen
diesen fall dass
eine corona infektion aus der schule
mitgebracht haben ist und ich jetzt
momentan oder mehr familien manager als
geschäftsführer bin vielen dank herr
roth erst mal dass sie uns ihre lage
einmal beschrieben haben und wir wollen
uns ja einen ganzen überblick in ganz
deutschland machen deswegen halten wir
jetzt zu katharina wolf nach lübeck
hallo katharina
hallo hallo aus lübeck wir sind hier in
buthmanns bierstuben der ältesten kneipe
lübecks und bei mir steht die inhaberin
harmonika zander frau zander wenn sie
von den forderungen von den schüler
hören und aus bayern das auch ihre
kneipe vielleicht dichtmacht gemacht
werden sollte was denken sie da ja frau
wolff also ich denke er sollte erst mal
vor seiner eigenen haustür kehren bevor
er sich um andere sachen gedanken macht
so eine schließung wenn sie ihre kneipe
wieder dicht machen müssten was würde
das für sie bedeuten das würde für mich
wieder bedeuten dass ich wieder hat es
hier einreichen muss wie bei den letzten
lockt das auch
der selbstständige gastronomen kann dann
nicht mehr von den umsätzen leben weil
ich habe dann keine umsätze mehr falle
wieder ins ziel hinein der letzte lockte
war schrecklich und er zog sich hin und
wir hatten keine perspektive und die
ganze gutbürgerliche kleinen gastronomie
wird durch diese locker und so diese
ständigen lockt das in meinen augen
kaputt gemacht die als gastronom müssen
immer als erste schließen und dürfen als
letzte auf machen obwohl wir hier die
beste möglichkeit haben um irgendetwas
zu kontrollieren die inzidenz in
schleswig holstein sind ja deutlich
besser als in bayern finden sie dass da
nicht unfair dass sie hier auch dicht
machen müssten dann das finde ich sehr
unfair weil deshalb ist doch auch diese
länder konferenz gewesen damit die
länderchefs selbstständig entscheiden
können wie sie in ihren landkreisen dann
agieren was meinen sie macht
schleswig-holstein besser als bayern
dass die zahlen besser sind das kann ich
ihnen auch nicht sagen das kann mir
nicht mal die politik erklären keiner
kann das erklären woher soll ich das
wissen
fehlt können sie nochmal erklären welche
konkreten konsequenzen die korona panini
schon für sie hatte sie mussten
mitarbeiter entlassen
sie haben die öffnungszeiten glaube ich
ändern müssen das ist richtig durch
diesen ellenlang lockdown sind mir
natürlich meine aushilfskräfte
weggebrochen was zur folge hatte dass
ich nicht mehr nur den sonntag
geschlossen habe sondern ich musste den
montag schließen jetzt durch diese 2 3g
regelung ist es so dass meine
schwiegertochter die hochschwanger ist
das auch nicht mehr so verkraftet weil
ich möchte auch nicht dass sie dann in
die bredouille kommt dass hier eine
kontrolle des ordnungsamtes kommt wo ich
auch von anderen gast gründung schon
gehört habe dass die nicht so sonderlich
nett abläuft und in ihrem
hochschwangeren zustand möchte ich hier
das nicht zumuten und deshalb muss ich
meine kneipe jetzt erst ab 17 uhr öffnen
es tagte die bund länder konferenz was
wären ihre konkreten wünsche forderungen
von den politikern jetzt
perspektiven einfach perspektiven zu
haben wie lange geht es kriegen wir
wieder gelder nach oder werden wir
einfach auf der straße sitzen gelassen
überbrückungs gelder wurden zwar jetzt
verlängert aber ob wir als gründungen
jetzt auch wieder davon etwas abkriegen
ich weiß es nicht
sie wollen in drei stunden ihren laden
hier offiziell wieder aufschließen und
hoffen dass noch möglichst lange ja
ja vielen dank nach lübeck und ich
glaube wir können der wird in etwas
hoffnung machen nach der
beschlussvorlage die uns bisher vorliegt
das ist die beschlussvorlage der cdu
geführten länder also auch schleswig
holstein wo daniel günther als
ministerpräsident regiert wird es für
die kneipen und für die gastronomie
keinen lockdown erst einmal geben clubs
und discos sind betroffen auch nicht in
schleswig-holstein überall aber in
anderen bundesländern das ist die
beschlussvorlage allerdings nur der cdu
geführten länder die spd geführten
länder sehen dass möglicherweise noch
anders also noch keine endgültige
entscheidung aber von kneipen und
gastronomie ist im moment jedenfalls
noch nicht die rede und wir gehen weiter
in eine weitere kneipe nach
nordrhein-westfalen nach ennigerloh
genauer gesagt wo unser kollege michael
engelberg ist
ja hallo zusammen aus ennigerloh enniger
liegt im kreis warendorf dass es im
schönen westfalen im münsterland und das
kann man auch tatsächlich sehen dass wir
im münsterland sind nämlich grünkohl mit
mettendchen und
bratkartoffeln das ist typisch
münsterländischer aber es kann sein dass
die küche hier tatsächlich demnächst
kalt bleibt neben heiko weitenberg der
chef vom landgasthof hohenheim ja jetzt
fordern bayern und sachsen einen harten
lockdown sind sie darauf vorbereitet
wenn es tatsächlich so kommen würde gut
ich glaube auf sowas kann man sich nur
schwer vorbereiten allerdings ist
natürlich schon so dass wir beim
wareneinkauf jetzt schon vorausschauend
planen dass wir eben nicht mehr die
üblichen mengen bestellen sondern eben
da schon ja nur noch fürs tagesgeschäft
ja ein paar sachen im glas haben ja
jetzt normalerweise wäre ja
weihnachtsfeier zeit hier würde die bude
brennen aber sie haben tatsächlich
andere erfahrungen gemacht er schildern
sonst mit der erfahrung aus den letzten
zwei wochen ja die letzten zwei wochen
die treiben einem eigentlich die tränen
in die augen wir haben jetzt wirklich
innerhalb dieser zwei wochen fast 1000
personen die uns storniert haben das ist
ein wirtschaftlicher schaden das kann
sich jeder hochrechnen wenn man nur ich
sag mal seinen deckel in der wirtschaft
bezahlt dann kann sich jeder ausmalen
wieviel schaden da entsteht aber es ist
ja eben nicht nur der finanzielle
schaden sondern auch ich sag mal das
knabbert so ein bisschen an der psyche
vor allen dingen auch für die
mitarbeiter ist das unheimlich schwierig
die jetzt wahrscheinlich auch wieder in
die kurzarbeit gehen müssen ja da greift
ein zahn wieder ins andere jetzt haben
wir gesehen sie haben sehr schön
eingedeckt nichtsdestotrotz haben sie
gerade gesagt kurzarbeit wie viele
mitarbeiter haben sie dann auf der
korona strecke schon verloren ja wir
kommen ursprünglich von sage ich mal gut
45 mitarbeitern sind natürlich ein teil
festangestellten teil 450 euro kräfte
und will pendel nun ziert so gerade
einmal knapp über 20 also fast halbiert
was sagen ihnen die leute denn wenn sie
jetzt stunden sind die da eher verschämt
oder wir würden ja gerne aber es klappt
nicht und wie reagieren sie darauf der
ja auch auf diese einnahmen angewiesen
ist sehr gut ich sag mal letztendlich
von meiner seite aus gibt es erstmal
verständnis in dieser zeit in dieser
schwierigen zeit muss die vernunft
siegen und ich glaube die vernunft ist
dann tatsächlich auch ja die sozialen
kontakte bzw die kontakte generell
einzudämmen nichtsdestotrotz also bei
den gästen gibt es von verschämt bis mir
doch egal alle reaktionen aber
letztendlich überwiegt gott sei dank
auch da sag ich mal zumindest die die
option auch noch mal wiederzukommen ja
wenn wir mal eben auf den spruch hier
eingehen eigentlich gibt es kaum etwas
schöneres auf erden als durst dem man
stehen kann ja das könnte jetzt
tatsächlich das ein bisschen ironie des
schicksals ironie des schicksals
eigentlich ist das ein spruch der im
sommer gelten sollte nicht dann wäre
hier hochkommt mit dem fahrrad dem hängt
die zunge auf dem sattel und dann ist es
natürlich wunderschön ein kaltes getränk
zur zurück zum stillen des durstes
bekommt jetzt ist es natürlich so dass
wir einfach gucken müssen in welche
richtung sich das weiter bewegt wir
haben ja heute noch die entscheidung der
politik die uns bevorsteht und ja wir
sind sehr gespannt in welche richtung
das geht jetzt haben wir gerade schon
ein bisschen die sendung verfolgt wir
sind ja quasi live dran zweig jetzt im
einzelhandel in hamburg wenn jetzt aber
jemand sagt so aber für die restaurants
müssen wir zweig plus machen das kann ja
da kann ja irgendeinen noch mit auf den
tisch kommen mit diesem vorschlag was
würde das für sie bedeuten also ganz
ehrlich gesagt rechne ich schon damit
zweig plus dass das jetzt auf uns
zukommt
das wird natürlich wiederum für unser
aller carte geschäft ja eigentlich ein
todesurteil sein denn wenn man mal eben
zum schnitzel essen gehen will oder sich
in grünkohl bestellt ob man dann
wirklich vorher los geht und sich testen
lässt wage ich zu bezweifeln
jetzt geht jetzt geht es darum
wie ist wie es weitergeht und
wir sitzen ja quasi mit der politik
zusammen am tisch der kollege runzheimer
da glüht das telefon welche forderungen
haben sie denn jetzt an die politik dass
es bei ihnen vernünftig weitergehen kann
damit sie überleben kann ja zum
überleben gehören natürlich immer auch
hilfen dazu ja ich denke einfach mal mit
den bisherigen hilfen sind wir
ansatzweise durch die krise gekommen und
wir wünschen uns wirklich dass das
verlängert wird dass es gegebenenfalls
jetzt auch für diese ganz akute zeit die
auf uns zukommt was mit der neuen
variante ist weiß auch noch niemand und
wenn es dann im dezember januar februar
tatsächlich so kommen sollte dass noch
weitere maßnahmen nötig sind dann
brauchen wir auch verlängerung der
hilfen also ohne finanzielle hilfe wird
dass die branche nicht schaffen unter
steht fest was hält sie denn da wirklich
noch über wasser das sie jeden tag wenn
geschäftszeiten sind den laden überhaupt
aufschließen
letztendlich muss man natürlich auch als
unternehmer zu sehen dass man sein
schiff durch die stürmische see
gesteuert kriegt das ist einfach so dass
ist auch ein stück weit
unternehmerisches risiko ja aber ich
glaube wenn wenn wir als branche oder
ich als chef jetzt das handtuch werfen
und sage ich kann nicht mehr ich will
nicht mehr ich habe keine lust mehr ich
glaube dass das falsche signal wir
wollen trotz alledem irgendwo noch den
gast ansatzweise zur verfügung stehen ja
also hier in ennigerloh wird gekämpft
und vielleicht kann das auch ein zeichen
sein für alle branchen die wirklich geht
auf der kippe stehen heiko weitenberg
und sein team kämpft und hofft weiter
arbeiten zu können zurück nach berlin
und wenn du mal kurz an die seite geht
dann sieht man was es da heute auf der
tageskarte gibt ich bin die ganze zeit
schon neidisch grünkohl mit mettendchen
das wäre es für 16 euro 90 und dazu noch
bratkartoffeln alles gute nach
ennigerloh ins schöne mitbringen was mit
gerne